[Music]
it's that time of the month again Sony
have announced the PlayStation Plus
lineup for January 2017 this month we
have a survival title puzzle bracing a
2d stealth action title and a 16-bit
adventure game as always let's kick off
with the big guns on ps4 first up is the
day of the tentacle remastered which is
also available on the Vita this is a
cartoon puzzle adventure originally
released in 1993 and is one of the
wittiest point and click games available
the story revolves around time travel
and ways to switch items through time to
solve puzzles occasionally the puzzles
are ridiculously long-winded but on the
whole this is worth your time if you are
below the age of 25 please let us know
if you're bothered about this one day of
the tentacle remastered holds a
Metacritic score of 84 and IGN gave it a
huge score of 8 point 8 out of 10
next up is the war of mine the little
ones a war survival game with the most
beautiful art style and tone which is
simply mind-blowing this is a strategy
title or you control a group of civilian
survivors during a war during daylight
hours hostile snipers make venturing
outside a nightmare leaving nighttime
your best option to fight Russians for
your friends and family this game is the
Pick of the month for me so please try
it out let me know what you think below
before we switch on to the ps3 please do
as a favor and hit the sub button as it
makes us feel all warm and fuzzy inside
come on up all month on PlayStation
granade is resident evil thief content
counting down the days to rest of evil 7
anyways let's get back to PS Plus the
first title on ps3 is blaze rush which
is a throwback to the 90s racing arcade
titles such as Micro Machines
this is a super chaotic and fun game
which is perfect for a night with a
family or a quick race or two with
friends single-player doesn't offer the
same amount of fun and online matches
can be hard to find but for a pickup and
play game
this is surprisingly fun the swindle is
a ps3 game which will also run on your
ps4 and Vita this is a stealth action
game about theft consisting of 100 days
you take on lasers minds and some pretty
huge people as you try and steal
everything in sight at the end of the
100 days a new computer AI will be
activated which will prevent you from
Tinh Ewing as a master thief if that
sounds interesting to you open give it a
go
current Metacritic score is 70 percent
let's move on to the Vita and remember
Vita games are usually accessible on the
ps4 so if you don't game on the go check
these out first up is tag team souls a
pixel art Zelda inspired outing in which
you play a boy with a single bone arrow
imagine Shadow of the Colossus if it was
made for the Super Nintendo and you're
pretty much on point there as Zelda is
locked to Nintendo machines this is
probably the closest we will get to
awesome top-down Zelda games of the
1990s as Ken to the world beneath is the
final offering and is basically
bejeweled Puzzle Quest or even candy
crush I'm not gonna oversell this one if
you like matching objects and colors
play this there is a story to but
ultimately this is a Facebook game okay
so that's it are you happy with what
we're getting this month and what will
you be downloading please let us know
below firstly I'm gonna try the war of
mine if you're new around here please
take a look at our other videos and if
you're a resident evil fan then please
stop in every day in January PlayStation
grenade is going resident evil crazy I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade I'll see
you next time
[Music]
you